do you play pranks on your mom um i
don't i do a little bit um my mother now
that i have money she likes to try to
get that from me
[Laughter]
so at the moment the moment she wants a
chair really badly i bought my father a
mercedes
and my mother got really jealous
and my mother is a morbidly obese person
who just sits in a lazy boy recliner and
watches tv and she goes you got your
father a 70 000 car but you didn't get
me anything and i go what can you get in
the space that you're sitting in yeah i
can buy you a new tv or whatever and so
the next time i went back now she has
all these chair catalogues everywhere
around the house
she wants a chair she looks like a lazy
boy one that will actually lift her up
to her feet like this like like you're
really giving up on life when you need a
chair to help you stand yeah anyway so
so she starts laying all these catalogs
around and then i just went oh that's a
nice chest and i just ignored it
and then uh all she wants is a chair i
know i bought her the chair it's coming
it's coming
but i have to make a sweat a little bit
right so so she rings me up going i need
to borrow four thousand dollars to buy
this chair and then i went all right mum
i'll see what i can do and then i got my
brother to write up a contract that was
a very reasonable rate right she goes i
can afford 150 dollars a month and i
said look i don't think you're going to
live that long i have to bump it up to
one time
there was another time she's she's she's
mad about chocolate right she likes
chocolate he's a big woman he loves
chocolate right and uh when i was living
in britain she decided that cadbury's
chocolate in britain was far superior
than that of the australian cadburys now
there's one ingredient that's different
there's just an emulsifier that stops it
melting so quick in australia right so i
was coming back from a bit i hadn't seen
my mother in about five years and all
she wanted was two big blocks of
cadburys chocolate so i bought them and
then on the way home i had to stop off
in hong kong now in hong kong
they sell australian cavalry so i bought
a couple of blocks of that as well right
right then as soon as i get in the car
she's like did you bring the chocolate
and so i gave them to her i gave her the
australian ones
she just turned into sean connery
[Laughter]
she starts unwrapping the chocolate like
she's a gossip glute looking for a
ticket
and she starts eating it's just oh oh
this is the best chocolate i've ever had
my god this is a good chocolate when
it's the australian one you're dosy
woman and this you had switched it out i
switched it out and now years later i i
got a girl pregnant that i've been
dating for a couple of months and i was
going to bring her back your story's
always have such a pleasant start to
them yeah
we're still good we co-parent anyway so
we were going back we were going back to
australia for the first time in years
and i was going to introduce it to my
girlfriend who was pregnant so i had a
lot of information to pass on and my
mother had decided that sea's chocolates
you know seas sure like a crappy
american chocolate like american
american chocolate's not good it's like
one up from carob
anyway so
man you're really i call that weird
uncle who always had a carob like yeah
it's a health food yeah yeah with your
anyway so
so so she's one of these seas chocolate
she only like strawberry creams and so
like my mother only likes gifts if
someone else has to struggle and be in
misery to give them to her like she
could just buy them and they'd be
delivered she needs you to carry it for
the thrill she's in your luggage that
kind of thing yeah she's like a sexual
abuser who needs the other person to be
in pain for them to feel good right
anyway so
not a good analogy no good
this is your mother for god's sake
anyway
anyway so she rings up my girlfriend who
she'd never met at the time she never
even met her and she goes oh i have
something for you to do
don't tell jim but i have two boxes of
seas chocolates arriving at the house
if you could smuggle them in your bag
and get them to me that would be great
so she's trying to use my girlfriend as
a chocolate meal yeah
and so my girlfriend comes down and
she's like she's like i have to ask you
something it's terribly difficult and
i'm like oh man i'm in trouble she's
heard she's gone through my phone or
something there's a big problem
and i was like okay i'm ready to listen
to this and then she goes your mother
called me about chocolate so i went all
right fine so what i did was i got the
chocolates and ate them all over skype
in front of her
[Laughter]
please tell me
please tell me a story where you end up
getting your mom sometimes okay first of
all my mother's an insulin dependent
diabetic i should actually bring that
into the conversation yeah she shouldn't
be having chocolates but she says what
if my sugar levels get too low and i
need to level them up i need chocolates
to save my life and i might go in the
kitchen and get some spoonfuls of sugar
you'll be fine
do you think so she needs sockets for
medical reasons so anyway so last time i
was going she asked me to get like like
four boxes of chocolates and i said i'm
not bringing him it's not happening
we've had the chocolate fight over so
ring me brother and my brother goes she
didn't she asked some more chocolate so
we rang up the people at seas and
between me and my brother we spent five
thousand dollars to get a big crate of
chocolate delivered to my mother because
that's a funny thing to do to a diabetic
because she'll never she'll never finish
the chocolate she'll have to throw it
away it's hilarious
anyway i wasn't sure until you explained
it to me so me and my father were like
this is the funniest thing we've ever
done we're dropping five grand we're
literally getting 5 000 chocolates
delivered on a pallet to a diabetic
we're the best anyway so
so we're doing this we've got all the
chocolates all stacked up all the time
and then the seeds ring us back and they
go uh we can't do the order and we're
like why not they go this is too weird
no one's ever ordered 5 000 strawberry
creams to australia no one's ever
ordered more than two boxes to australia
we won't do it right because they just
said it was they wouldn't do it and then
they said that they rang me up and they
go they go what we'll do is we can
deliver
nine boxes and i said don't do that
she'll enjoy that
it's gonna be ridiculous
you know all this is a is a great
reminder that sunday's mother's day it
is mother's day
not in australia
yeah yeah
no there is there is mother's day but
it's in like some other month i don't
know what it is but i don't i don't have
to i don't know when i don't know it is
but i don't have to remember it because
it's a different date in australia yeah
i just forget all the time or you see
some facebook posts you know i sent us
some flowers never never chocolates yeah